oh [ __ ]
oh god help me hey i'm alexa senior food
specialist here at tasty my friends have
challenged me to cook with a coffee
maker
i did that a clothing iron i did that
too but let's see what my producer has
in store at this time
oh boy you have yourself a microwave
however you cannot do any research that
seems fair
i feel like i probably need to elevate
it a bit more than a mug cake
good luck my friend thank you
i feel like this is too easy like i'm
being tricked microwaves are a really
common kitchen appliance that people use
to cook with
every day i know i could make a meal in
a microwave but i really want to
challenge myself to make something
really unexpected
do i feel good maybe
for the first course i'm going to make
beet dyed deviled eggs
as i was going to get eggs someone was
like eggs are going to explode in the
microwave so
i'm going to put the beet in this dish
and pour a little water in it so it like
kind of
steams to cook it
maybe five minutes three minutes i'll
start
start start slow okay
start
okay oh there's a potato function on
here and a beet
is kind of similar to a potato
we wait
i mean this is great that it has the
potato function take some
guesswork out but it takes 12 minutes
it's gonna be a long day i feel antsy i
feel like excited to see if this works
i'm impatient let's see oh we're good
so i'm just going to boil the vinegar
and water and salt that i'm going to add
the beet
what am i doing okay well i found the
express time which is 30 seconds so
maybe i'm going to be
doing everything in 30 second intervals
so because the beet is
tender now i can actually just peel the
skin right off oh my god this is going
to be crazy
[Music]
so if i was doing this at home i would
do it in an oven roast it
doesn't really matter what size they're
cut into it's just for dying
the pickling liquid the pickling liquid
looks really beautiful color is really
intense this beautiful magenta
i'm gonna do this one i'm so bad at this
yeah what am i doing wrong like i just
wanted to go
oh wait what did you just do would you
just press buttons
but why when i did that didn't work
okay so if you were gonna hard boil an
egg but in a microwave
seven minutes that feels aggressive i'm
gonna go with six minutes we can do it
again
moment of truth cool it down just a hair
i feel so nervous
i'm doing a really bad job peeling this
egg but it's so hot
the white feels very very cooked i
honestly hadn't considered if it was
overcooked
[Music]
there's a really good egg i'm just gonna
cool these down so i can actually peel
them the longer you let the egg sit in
the pickling liquid the more
pink it'll get i've been feeling nice
for about 25 minutes now but i'm on my
last one
i'm gonna move on to the lemon bars
is where my confidence starts to wane
i'm gonna melt some
butter for the crust so i've got some
flour
powdered sugar pinch of salt i'm going
for a faux
shortbread crust per usual i'm just
wondering if a crust is actually
going to cook in a microwave this isn't
like an oven and i'm not
able to really bake it so i think the
key for this is going to go slowly like
doing it in increments and checking
just so nothing gets really like fried
i'm going to press this down
it's not the finest crust i've ever made
it's a bottom layer
[Music]
pizza probably to reheat pizza maybe
i'll just do two minutes
and see what happens
it's kind of cooking baking i think i'll
do
two more minutes and see what happens
i really want to make sure that the
flour is no longer
raw if we can get a firm crust that'd be
great so i have these amazing lemons
they're meyer lemons
so this is what i'm gonna use to make my
curd and i'm gonna try to make candied
lemon peel
with these like beautiful smooth lemons
[Music]
oh no it's burnt the good
news is that there is some color
on the crust bad news is that i burnt
this but let me give it a
[Music]
taste
don't love the texture i'm just gonna do
it again for less time
and see what happens it smells really
bad in here
here we go i'm gonna multitask and at
least get the lemon peels in some hot
water
the thing is i can't look up any of this
stuff so all the timing and the voltage
is just
what i think is right and i don't know
what's right so to candy lemons
first add the peels to boiling water to
remove the bitterness
butter is good add this back in
research would have been really nice i'm
just going to say that
i'm also going to fork prick because
some of the air can get out i think that
might help too
i'll do two minutes two minutes and then
like one minute and see what happens
and then i'm gonna make a simple syrup
with sugar and water this feels a little
chaotic right now but
um no
it's getting like a dark spot in the
middle why is this happening
maybe this is fine i mean this is like a
pale pale pale pale pale crust
put you over here into the microwave
meyer lemons have a more sweet subtle
flavor than
traditional lemons they're amazing sugar
and water
are dissolved add the peels in and
usually you would simmer this over
really low heat but again can't do that
so i'm just going to let it
hang out so we've got the eggs sugar a
pinch of salt
and i'm gonna add a pinch of cornstarch
and then
lemon juice
that's a butter so far this is like you
would make
regular curd i'm gonna try microwaving
it in
one minute intervals if this doesn't
work we'll just do it again
it feels like i've like buried my nose
inside of a burnt popcorn bag
it's hard to imagine that this is going
to thicken
this so usually you'd be simmering it
but it actually looks like pretty thick
and syrupy
it smells really good
[Music]
so one thing is going well we're gonna
have just candied lemon peel for dessert
[Music]
oh it does thicken oh my god
kind of chunky but i'm gonna taste it
i think i'll put it through the sieve to
get any chunks out
i wonder if this is enough now i guess
i microwave it again so if i was doing
this at home
i would put it in the oven for a few
minutes just to help
it set maybe express i'm going back to
express that feels right
30 seconds i'm going to slice up my
little candied lemon peel and toss it
with some sugar and let it dry
i think i'm just gonna chill it and hope
for the best we're
finally at the entree i'm going to make
tomato chips
creamy polenta and halibut i have this
idea to
not roast garlic but kind of get that a
similar thing i'm going to
lop the top off bowl olive oil
salt so i would usually just
roast this really low and slow for a
while but let's see what happens
if we do potato one
five i also have this idea to make
tomato chips
and actually do a little salt the salt's
just gonna draw some more moisture out
of them just because i want them to be
as dry as possible when i do put them in
the microwave
i'm gonna try to make polenta i'm gonna
use milk you could use chicken stock you
could use water
maybe the milk is a bad idea in this
case but adding some salt
i need to wash like something is fishy
here something's wrong
had to intervene sorry smoking
oh no ah
oh it's like on fire i don't want to say
this is a disaster
quite yet but this is really not going
very well
well garlic was best which changes
some things so i'm gonna move on to the
polenta and see if this works
you know maybe it was potato maybe
potato was too intense
it's so hot in here it's like at least
80 degrees and it smells like burnt
popcorn
this is going badly how do i feel about
this
not good my confidence level right now
is honestly at a
like a three at least i have candied
lemon peel
voila thing is i can't let my confidence
level dip too far
because then i'm gonna start messing up
it's not over yet
oh my god i honestly like
i this is a disaster what is happening
i mean maybe it's fine
no no no no no no
that's not good this is the unraveling
have you taken me down in three episodes
so i'm gonna put one fillet
i put some tarragon some thyme
and some capers would you like to ask my
confidence level
it's about it two it's sinking right
down
remember when i was like i'm gonna
inspire people to cook in their dorm
rooms
fly butter see how this goes i am so
nervous
like what if i just don't do it
feels right so i can just let these
heat oh speaking of all the smells i'm
now the person who puts fish in the
microwave
yeah i got cocky i knew it was a trick
knew it was too good to be true
hmm it feels a tiny bit overdone to me
i can put something on the plate i'm
gonna cook off
some more fish for real this time i feel
like i should save one just in case
[Music]
i think my fish is done let's just
see what happens when we put tomatoes in
the microwave look at those eggs this is
really the moment of truth
oh they're beautiful
the eggs feel a little hard not gonna
lie the magenta here is like even more
intense than some of the ones i've made
in the past but i
really like it this is going to be
really simple
mayonnaise it's a mustard call it a day
it's not great it's not great
maybe they will be distracted by how
pretty they are
these are not the most um delicate
total decks i've ever made but little
eggs were my friends
little eggs they're so cute oh my god
okay i'm gonna chill these in the fridge
and top them with chives and bacon
at the end i guess i should see the
lemon bars huh the curd
looks good it's not really a pretty even
layer here but
[Music]
you guys this is not good
i don't know if we could really call
this a lemon bar
i'm stressing it it's fun
if i can just get one nice square i'll
be
thrilled
[Music]
there's a square i mean look it's not
fully set
if i can just plate things really
beautifully maybe it'll distract them
no this is not a thing no one wants to
eat this a soggy tomato
anyone it's fine someone's just gonna
get fish
what is the plan bacon's last thing
words of wisdom
no no good good
is there a bacon function bacon in the
microwave
[Music]
how to do this thing i'm just worried of
whoever tastes this is going to be like
oh you're a
terrible cook
guys that's not good rubbery is kind of
like the theme of today
honestly this is as good as it's gonna
get right now do i get to know who's
gonna try this
no it's a surprise
come oh god well this is my new boss
i've prepared a three-course meal i'm so
excited
i'm so excited for you too the first
course are
beet-dyed deviled eggs with chives and
bacon
so beautiful thank you so much i'm going
to try to eat this elegantly
i think there's no way
that's pretty delicious all right
the bacon is really crispy the egg
whites are
the chinese bit rubbery honestly other
than that i think it's pretty delicious
okay of course too it's more of a
minimalist
thing it's a halibut just taliban the
plating is really pretty
should i just leave it's fine
it's not my favorite fish dish sure fine
fine feels like a badge of honor right
now
for your third course you have a lemon
bar with some candied
lemon peel on top it's more of a candy
your own lemon i did
the crust is so crunchy in a great way
because the curd is super smooth
the first and the third were really good
i really don't know what phrases you had
to do
to get to this place but not bad well do
you want to know
what what they put me up laid out for me
you gotta turn around
did you cook it in this microwave all
three courses done in a microwave
fish in my grill how did you get the
crust so crispy the first one burned
which is why the room smells like this
i was concerned about the burning fume
smell when i came in
but i'm super impressed that you did
that in the microwave
like a stove i'm gonna go ahead and take
this oh i'm gonna finish it with someone
there
thanks thanks oh that was
by far the hardest thing i've ever had
to do here i hate microwaves it turns
out i never want to cook with one again
but i also feel like maybe i have
redemption in my future
if i can research no
hopefully next time will be easier
better
honestly give me a coffee maker again
[Music]
you